And I remember seeing for the first time
I was telling Scotty I just recalled it
that you know the two bodies together in
front of me and literally I had to walk
outside and I almost was sick. Warning,
this episode may contain content that is
not suitable for children. Viewer
discretion is advised.
Welcome to LED Live. So you wake up one
day and you're working in the porn
industry. What is that really like?
Find out on this episode of LED Live.
Lights exposing darkness.
You guys are going to like this topic
today. In fact, um you know we've been
talking about pornography on our show
from time to time and it's something
that we feel passionate about. There's a
lot of people that this industry
affects, touches,
um and you know today's topic really I I
have a friend that I want to introduce
you to. John, welcome to the show.
John I've known for a few years now and
uh I actually did not know the extent of
of your involvement in this industry
until we actually chatted the other day.
I mean I I remember talking with you a
little bit and you had kind of mentioned
you know that you had a a run-in with
the porn industry but I didn't know at
what level that that transpired to be.
So I'm excited to uh bring you guys a
very interesting story and topic. Uh
John, welcome to our show.
Thank you, Scotty. It's good to be here,
bro. Good to be here. Like I said I I've
been here a thousand times or a hundred
times of it to be inside of it it's
really cool. Um and yeah you know one of
the reasons you had said in your before
we came on live we were uh Scotty had a
prayer for us. He had talked about the
idea of keeping some of our stuff in the
rearview mirror and not bringing it
forward. And I know one of the reasons
why it's not an advertizable thing in my
life is I feel that way. I know when I
first sort of came across I noticed
myself talking to people as if it was a
positive cuz like you know even in my
Christian experience but you know it
it's very
it's it's it's hard to separate that and
so I noticed as I gave my testimony I
felt over time that there was this thing
about is it this cool what I did and
what I've done, right? And so I sort of
just stopped making that a part of what
I was saying cuz I didn't it was just
difficult. So but I was excited about
the opportunity to sort of expose or or
bring my experience to bear cuz this
this is everywhere. This is prevalent
and I've seen statistics. It's not just
prevalent in our society it's prevalent
in our church, right? So That's right. I
think if everyone were to be honest I
mean I've heard numbers as high as 90%
of ni- in the 90s percent of people like
actually interact with this. I mean
I'm sure there's nobody sitting at this
table that has never been exposed to
this. If we're all honest this is a
business that that has affected a lot of
people and
like the devil likes to do he likes to
get in the middle of our relationships
and this is one of those things that
just really attacks a core fundamental
thing about humanity. Um you know we've
always heard that food and sex are the
two things that you need in life, right?
Well
for most people if you're married yes
but God designed us to have this
chemical bond with people and in a
special way done underneath the umbrella
that God has has specifically set up and
the devil just takes that, twists it,
taints it and puts it out there in this
fantasy world. And so I think um you
know a lot of people fantasize about
what this industry really is or what
it's about or or what's even involved in
it. So it's not every day that you get
to talk with somebody that's actually
worked behind the scenes in this. So I'm
a little excited to to kind of get into
your story. So I just want to say one
thing before we jump into that. I was
doing a talk recently and I I did a
little bit of research for it
and found out that during the
what you might call
what people were saying like the height
of the pandemic in in the US, you know
it's like February, March type range.
Depending on the country you're in
the traffic to Pornhub increased
between 4 and 24%. Wow.
Wow.
you're a business Yeah. I mean do the
math. A 4% all the way up to a 24%
increase
you'd be super excited, right? That's
right that represents a lot of people
though. And so what are they doing with
their time? Yeah. Right? All the extra
time that they have? Well there's at
least 4 to 24% of the population that
was you know going to that. And you
shared a stat with us a while back about
the viewership of Pornhub how it's like
um YouTube and Netflix It was it was
greater than like Instagram or Twitter
or something.
Yeah. Yeah. Staggering. And and and
what's crazy too is is the age that I
think people are actually accidentally
and I say that accidentally getting
exposed to it is becoming lower and
lower.
Like I can I can remember the first time
that that that uh that topic was brought
up where I actually saw some photographs
or something I was probably third grade
was about the time that that I remember
first being exposed to it. And I have
now since heard I mean I just had a
conversation in the kitchen the other
day of of a lady that works here and a
four-year-old was telling her about his
his exposure and it's like four years
old. I can't even it can't even fathom
that. So this is this is a a much needed
topic and um you know I'm I'm I'm
curious to see a little window behind
what's actually going on in that
industry. So tell us a little story. The
whole framework of Sorry. Yeah, how'd
you get involved in all this?
Exactly.
So um
I was in it's in the So my the time
frame for my involvement in the
pornography industry was in the late 80s
between like sort of 85, 86 through
um 89 or 90. Um you know there were
probably two years in there it was
really hardcore and before it was
before and after were sort of you know
petering in the petering out. So at the
time there was lots of video going on.
The internet was just getting started
and and so what happened was my
brother-in-law my married my sister
married a gentleman from Indiana who had
a mail order company and he had figured
out a way to send out you know ads and
he would he would he would he was making
a lot of money in mail order. And so he
decided some of the guys that he was
buying from realized how well he was
doing and started jacking his prices up.
So he decided to come on the coast and
shoot his own product. And so he came on
the coast and um when he came out here I
I was living here in California and he
was sort of shy, retiring man if you can
think about it that way and sort of live
vicariously through me. My my
personality was brighter. I was a little
bit more sort of LA-ized. And so he took
me under his wing and and at the time I
was doing nothing you know I was doing
anything I was doing was nefarious. It
was sort of buy low, sell high. Typical
LA lifestyle figuring out where you can
make some money. And so when he came he
went with a proposition. He said listen,
why don't you just go on one of the sets
and just be a production assistant,
right? Just to sort of get me involved.
And so and so he hooked me up with a
director named Ron Jeremy which he was
working with and so I went on the set
with Ron and I was just production
assistant and sort of you know doing
little things here and there. And I want
to stop there. I had told Scotty the
other day and I'd forgotten about this
but the first time he brought me on a
set they were they had rented a suite in
the Beverly Hills Hotel and they had
blacked all the windows out and they
were doing a movie up there in one of
the bungalows. And I remember seeing for
the first time I was telling Scotty I
just recalled it that you know the two
bodies together in front of me and
literally I had to walk outside and I
almost was sick. Now I'm 23, 24 years
old. I am as pagan as they come. I have
every bad habit in the world. This
should not appall me. But my Christian
background and I just looking at that
and I did not expect it. Wasn't
something I thought was going to happen.
I walked in there with like yeah, what's
going on guys? You know I'm part of this
and and I watched it just just it moved
me that this really. It was it was a
weird situation so it took me a while to
get in to get acclimated to what I was
seeing in front of me. Um so I started
production assisting a little bit and
then
then I started directing and so for a
couple years I was I was Leisure Time's
director
of movies. So that that was kind of a
fast transition there. It went like from
mail order to next thing you know you're
directing like did you know what you
were getting into? I mean it was oh yeah
I just need you to come in and be a
director or did you know oh yeah this is
a porn shoot?
So truth be told I had um I had um
done some nefarious business with my
brother-in-law. He had a lot of money. I
always needed a lot of money and so I'd
done some stuff and I found myself on
the wrong end of the ledger card. And so
he had it was actually an invitation to
me to work off some of the the you know
the the money I'd taken from him and so
he was bringing me in just to sort of So
I wasn't it wasn't me looking to get
into the business. It was him using his
relationship with me to get me in there
cuz he cuz he liked to share like when
we when we'd come off of sets the first
thing we would do is John let's go to
lunch. How did it go? Tell me about
so-and-so. Tell me about so-and-so. He
liked to live it through my eyes. And I
realized after a couple lunches that's
what was happening here is he was I was
his proxy into what was the world going
on there and I would so um so it was
like that more key that wasn't that I
was transitioning from mail order model
into a
video model. He had just asked me to
come in there and
and work off some money that I owed him
and then pretty soon it
grew beyond that. Isn't that interesting
how like when you first get exposed to
like some very dark sin or something,
right? That there's this natural
inclination to be like repulsed by it or
or shy away from it. I mean I I remember
the first time I smoked cigarettes I
turned green as that color on this light
in this table right here. I mean I was
green. Why would I do it again? Your
body It makes sense. It's like you're
you're like a dog returning to the
vomit, you know? And it's like pretty
soon you you look forward to the vomit
and then you're eating it shortly
thereafter. So so you're getting
involved in this. You're 25 years old.
Where where does this lead? Where is it
going?
So you know in my heart of hearts being
you know having
had a Christian background but again
having no Christian worldview and having
no Christian future. I was absolutely,
you know, paganized. I knew I didn't
want to spend the rest of my life being
involved with this stuff. I was very
fortunate in that growing up, you know,
pornography wasn't part of my
It was one of my sin sex, if you will. I
had drug issues, I had smoking issues, I
had, you know, honesty issues.
Pornography wasn't one of them. I think
I'd seen one video.
And as ironically, I work with her like
a year into my I was like, "Wow, you're
person I ever have seen do this before."
So, I wasn't looking at it for as a
career path. I was looking at to make
money. And it To be honest with you, it
was kind of
heady at the time. Most of the folks
that were in my position were much older
than I, not in as good of shape as I.
I was just sort of It was It was I was
an outlier. And I was enjoying the
adoration, etc. I knew it was
short-lived. I knew I wasn't going to be
here forever.
I had a wife and three kids at the time.
And so, I was coming home. I was going
to make movies. I couldn't tell my
children, you know, what kind of movies
I made. Thank God they were younger. So,
I didn't really have to have those
conversations with them. But as they
were getting older through this process,
it became more and more, you know, the
6-year-old became eight and wanted to
know why dad was going to San Francisco
for 3 days. He's going to make movies.
You know, well, what kind of movies When
can I watch them? That type of thing.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Yeah, so how is your wife with this? I
mean, is she okay with you actually
producing these videos?
You know, interesting, you know, my wife
was part of the family. So, she knew,
you know, Mark and she knew everybody.
So,
you know,
you know, that the the wife part of her
wasn't happy. But having said that, you
know,
um
it's a different It's a different show
for you. But there there are
relationships where one person just
wants to keep the other person so badly
that they're willing to turn a blind eye
to things. It was sort of like that,
right? And so, it's it's sort of a don't
ask, don't tell type of a thing, you
know? So. Mm, man. You know, that's
that's
Yeah, that's that's got to be a hard
position to be in cuz, you know, I think
about my own marriage and and, you know,
there's just there's just so much
intimacy there that you want like, you
know, to have that person, you know,
know all the little details of your life
and have a an area or a corner that it's
like, okay, this is off limits and, you
know, it seems like that would just just
be a bad situation from the onset. But
praise God you're here. I mean, you've
you've obviously come out of that. So,
what what kind of brought you out of
this?
That's a That's a great question.
Um
So, as as I progressed through and
became less and less enamored with what
was going on cuz anything becomes work
after a while, right? And so, if you
take a a trip up to Big Bear for 4 days
and you're tasked with making four
movies and you have grips and gaffers
and, you know, lighting people and and
and talent. And these talent they're
always, you know, doing drugs in the
back room and they're not reliable. It
becomes a chore as well, right? And so,
so it became a little bit of a grind
like that as well. But, you know, I was
making really, really good money. My
brother-in-law was taking great care of
me and I work my own hours. So, so it
was sort of like that. But what really
began to wear at me was my children
began to grow up. And my oldest
daughter, her name is
Sorry, it's Summer. And she was six and
then she was seven and then she was
eight. And so,
I started looking at the girls in the
set guys as them. I realized that each
woman on my set was somebody's daughter.
I mean, literally speaking, I
you know, I held my daughter in my arms
and I started picturing each of the
girls in the set at some point had a
father and mother who looked at their
life and their life trajectory was
excited about what God what whatever was
going to happen in their lives.
Were they going to be an attorney? Were
they going to be, you know, what they
were going to be? And I realized that
they were 18, they were 21, they were
23. And they were in my room and I was
filming them having sex with other men.
And it just began to grate on me that
somewhere out there was a John whose
daughter And I started thinking about my
daughter and just putting all the ends
together, it began to really wear on me
in such a way that, you know, I you
know, I was in my again mid-20s making
great money and I I walked away That was
That was the reason. I just could no
longer look at myself in the mirror,
come to work. I
I saw them differently. And so, when you
see them differently, you don't see them
as animals. You don't see them as as
something that's a a means to an end. If
you start connecting with them through
your heart, you're going to get stuck. I
mean, you get you have you have stuff to
get through, you have scenes to do, you
have you have things that need to get
happening. You cannot see them as
people. And so,
and so, I I just called my
brother-in-law one day and he would, you
know, I I would get tired after shows
and he would drive down and live in
Sweden at the time and he would knock on
the door and wake me up and tell my wife
he's writing me more checks, but he told
John to come out of retirement cuz I
would, you know, I'd leave cuz it was it
was not only physically exhausting, it
was emotionally and spiritually
exhausting, you know, as I began that
new trek. And then one day I just said
it, "I'm done." And I just said, "It's
over." emptying you. You know, you bring
up a really good point. I think that a
lot of people don't see You see, they
see the facade of pornography. They see
the only one side of it. They actually
don't see the the person that's behind
that window. And And maybe you can kind
of speak to this for a little bit I and
maybe you guys have some questions. But
I've heard that a large portion of these
girls, especially in today's pornography
world, are trafficked. And they're not
there voluntarily. They don't want to be
there. I mean, literally off of the set,
their handlers are sitting there forcing
them to do those things. And to the
viewers, it's like if you just had that
mentality like, this could be my sister.
This could be my my my daughter. This
could be, you know, somebody that that I
know very well. And you would begin to
see them as different. And hopefully
that would that would repel you from
wanting to engage in that because
really, if nobody watched it, nobody was
involved in it, nobody bought it, Yeah,
it wouldn't sell. There would be no
industry.
And to piggyback off of that, you
actually said you had to change your
perspective from viewing these people as
animals to actual human beings. Can you
speak to how those the talent, as you
call them, are treated, especially when
a monetary value is added on their
worth?
Absolutely. That's That's a great That's
a great, great question. You know, I
will I will
respond to that by saying this. I'll
sort of give you a gateway or a little
better frame. So, at the time that I was
working, we had a There was a talent an
agency. It was a porn agency called
World Modeling. It was in Van Nuys on
Van Nuys Boulevard. And so, what they
would do is they put ads in papers
across the country saying, "Come to
Hollywood, be a star." And they would
track them that way. So, there's no
handlers, there was no, you know, forced
sort of slavery. Having said that,
slavery doesn't have to be bondage,
right? You can be enslaved to your your
your dreams and your aspirations, your
desires to be seen as a human being,
your desires to be a part of something
bigger than you are.
And so, so these girls would come They'd
flock in and we'd go to the to the the
modeling agency and we had little cards
we'd fill out and we'd take pictures of
them. And then when we do shows, we
would go through our files and look. And
so, invariably these girls, like I said,
they weren't they weren't trafficked.
So, obviously I was friendly, obviously
there was there was an interaction going
on there. But to to your question,
um
I began to
look beyond
the response to see what was in her
eyes, their emotions. And I realized
there's a lot of things I wasn't seeing.
If I was asking someone to do something,
I wasn't seeing there was a little bit
of a reticence. There was a little bit
of a
of of a void back there. I just And I'm
not sure if I projected that or if I
just was blind to it earlier. But our
interactions became more
I began to analyze them more and
realized that there was a lot of holes
back there. One of the things I I talked
to Scotty about before the the show is,
you know, everyone grows up with a hole
in the heart that's God-shaped, as we
say, right? God has this
We We have a need for affirmation, need
for validation, need for purpose, right?
All those things are in our hearts. And
pornography for these actors, these
talent, as I call them, that's just a
way to fill that void, right? And so,
these girls are filling that void and
many of them came from sexually abused
backgrounds. Many of them came from
backgrounds where their father had left.
There There was a
the pain and misery index, if you really
were to read it correctly, which like I
said, I did not initially, was off the
charts both for for boys and girls. And
so, I guess the answer to questions I
needed to
to note that pain and misery index in a
way that had them them looking like
wounded individuals rather than I was
telling Scotty earlier, they come on the
set saying, "I'm free. Society out there
puts these bondages on you. You have
these handcuffs about purity and being
puritanical. We don't play that. We're
free of all that." So, they come with
this liberty and this sort of joy to
state joy. But when you drill into it,
you realize that they're just in bondage
to something different. They're not
free. They're as free as the drug addict
is free from his drugs. They're as free
as the alcoholic is free from their
alcohol, right? They're not free.
Um and so, I began to notice those sorts
of things in the background. Um
and
you know, just sort of riff on what And
then you can stop me for questions
whenever you want to. The lifespan of
these girls is very short.
We would I would call them killer and
filler. When you do a video, you need
someone to put on the box cover. She's
the one who gets paid, you know,
potentially more than the rest of girls.
The rest of the ones we called filler.
And I didn't I don't say that
pejoratively. It's just we called it
killer and filler. And so, the filler
girls the killer girls could go, you
know, 12 months, 18 months, as long as
your video went out and it sold lots of
copies, you could make another movie as
as killer and command a higher rate. The
moment that video went down, you're no
longer anything, you know? Some you
know, some transcended, you know, the
Tracy Lords of the world, you know, sort
of transcended. But that was that was
their life. The filler, oh, wow. I mean,
you know, 8, 9 months.
Um and again, we're talking that you
know, their their shelf life has nothing
to do with their value or their quality.
Their shelf life has to do with money
and whether or not they can be marketed.
And so, if you're a filler with nothing
other than than your, you know,
willingness to do certain things, you
know, you're 6, 7, 8 months and you're
done, right? It's not at your whim. You
can't extend You can't extend your your
your stay there because you have value
or quality. And when you mean done, do
you mean like these girls are like
wrecked not only emotionally, but drugs,
strung out, like their life has just
fallen apart and they are literally
valueless?
That I was going to I was going to sort
of bifurcate that. If they weren't If
they weren't done with respect to
relative to someone hiring them, they
were done in the way you just described,
Scotty. And some of them both at the
same time. Drug use rampant on the sets.
Um, you know, I when I hired grips and
gaffers, I used to
you know,
I made arrangements with them to make
sure that I they they were allowed to
come on the set and ply their business,
but not to the guys and not before the
scenes, right? Because it was so it was
going to happen, I just had to control
it and and and monitor it to my to my
advantage, right? So, yes. And you know,
for us, we know what that is, right?
That's guilt. That's shame. That's that,
you know, that's what, you know, who
told you you were naked. That's what
that is, right? And they don't see it as
that. And so, they they see it as
freedom and then and then drugs and
alcohol um sort of
numb that pain and turn it into quote
unquote joy and celebration when but but
it's it's a killer, you know.
Yeah, you you're saying all this and I'm
reminded of the episode we did with Chad
and how he brought all these statistics.
And
participating in sexual acts in excess
actually reduces your happiness. It
actually wears you down um whether
you're in this industry or maybe in the
privacy of your own home. So, keeping
that in mind that it's it's
scientifically proving what you're
uh back science is backing up what
you're saying about the life lifespan,
so to speak, of of these people who are
participating that in that world in in
excess. But I had a follow-up question
to the question I asked before because
you were um
you were addressing the internal turmoil
that these girls were going through. Um
but when you were talking about the
first time you you were ever on set, you
were repulsed by what was going on. If
you watch any like sci-fi or or action
film, a lot of the times the set looks
very different from what you see on
screen. Like it looks flashy and
beautiful and all of that. I always
wonder and and how it was actually
filmed is just in this like green box
and the actor has to like visualize to
to make it look realistic. Is it the
same in that world where on screen it
looks flashy and nice and beautiful, but
in reality the people who are actually
there filming it's actually pretty
pretty bad?
I identical. And first of all, I just
full disclosure, my brother-in-law was
known as the um
Actually, Allison know this, you know,
the the the coda, right? So, they they
are the the coda of the He was the coda
of the of the porn industry. He made
things on very small budgets and so I
wasn't working with great sets and I I
did what I could. Um but to your point,
um
so
when you edit something, it can look
beautiful with music and and you know,
good-looking bodies doing whatever they
do. To get that footage, you stop just
like anybody else does and you cut and
you say you move your left leg and you
do this. And you know, you can see the
it's not pretty. It's not fun. I mean,
so yes, it's very and I love your your
your your your point, Candy, cuz um
it does wear them down. I mean, I I
suppose if you just were to capture
somebody doing what they do, that'd be
one
level of degradation. But when you stop
and you break it down, you make them do
this and
I mean, one of the one of the things I
had to stop doing when I came off the
set was I realized that I was so
acclimated to saying certain things that
you say on a set about, you know, moving
objects and doing, you know, with body
parts, it took me 6 to 12 months to not
have that as part of my vocabulary or
hear it in a way that was nails on a
chalkboard because for years that's what
I did, you know?
So, and I won't
you know, you can just imagine what they
are. So, that that's what they're
getting every day and every moment as
they film what they're filming and has
to be just as degrading for them. It's
so satanic to think about something so
beautiful that God designed. I mean,
something that is meant to stick you
together. And And keep in mind, these
are actors.
There's a reason why they call them
actors, right? They're acting. They This
is not a pleasurable experience for
probably many of them, right? I mean,
they're not
totally into this. This is this is a job
like anything else and and what they're
portraying is this like fantasy world of
like they're they're really enjoying
this and and and what not, but yeah, I
mean, I I've never been on set before,
but I've heard enough pieces and parts
of the puzzle to know that, you know,
they they're not having fun. This is
This is not fun to them. So, I have a
question. You mentioned previously
um that
you guys would put an ad out and the
talent would respond to those ads. And
then, you know, you you'd take pictures
and and and look at you know, their
photos and stuff.
What What is the extent of that? What do
they think that they're walking into
because
I'm I'm I'm trying to imagine, are you
putting out an ad that says be a porn
star or you just saying put an ad out
that says be a star in Hollywood?
Because I can imagine going to the ad
agency,
those are two entirely different things
and to progress from what you think it
is to what it actually is,
it would seem like there's some
profiling going on there.
You know, No.
I love the question, Keith, and I'll
I'll I'll be clear I'll I'll try to
provide some clarity there. First of
all, I'm not in no way, shape or form
saying that what my part was better or
worse than the part I'm going to
describe, but the part you're talking
about wasn't my part. This ad agency
would send ads out and they and he'd be
talked about, you know, semi-nude or
nude and he'd work them down to me. I
was at the bottom of the pole, right?
So, he'd work them or guys like me, not
just me, right? So, video was at the end
of the the rainbow. So, you know, don't
bring them in for video. Some, I guess,
do jump right away. But this agency
would do the work you just described,
which is saying, "Listen, um you know,
go here and you'll have to maybe take
your shirt off or show something." And
then now that that pays 150. But if you
want to make this much money, here's
what's waiting for you. And so, he would
bring them down the chain. Of course,
the end of the chain was was video. And
and that was done before me. So, the
girls the the talent that I saw in the
in the room already knew that I was a a
guy for video and they'd already chosen
that path. Again, not saying that my
part was at all worse, but that was done
prior to me. So, that that leads me to a
follow-up question then. And maybe you
know this, maybe you don't. Because that
sounds very similar to the steps that
people take when you're pushing them
into suicide. You know, you push them a
little further and a little further and
a little further and a little further
and next thing you know, you've pushed
them over the edge.
So, because it sounds similar, I'm
wondering
how many of those people that you knew
aren't alive today?
You know, I there were um
the the the the Facebook and the
internet wasn't alive around in those
days, so I had just I have a really good
friend that
a gentleman um
Tony Montana, he wouldn't mind if I said
his name, but he was that was his stage
name and he's a buddy of mine. He
actually lives in and
um over the hill. So, I have there's a
few I keep in contact with, but he's
told me over the years that many of them
have committed suicide. I don't stay in
touch. I don't know the the numbers. Um
but
you know, you know, and I don't want to
paint just a one color, you know,
monochromatic picture them. These are
all three-dimensional people. We're
talking about Ron Jeremy. Ron Jeremy is
an amazing individual on his own.
Not many people know his background. Ron
Jeremy is from New Jersey and before he
got into the business, he was a special
ed teacher for third, fourth, and fifth
graders. Tremendous heart, tremendous
compassion for humanity, very
intelligent. Um but he found he had this
skill that people would adore him for
and so he followed that part of it, but
he never that piece was always alive in
him. We'd be on sets for hours talking
and stuff and he was
um
he was So, you have that background as
well. You have people that wanted to use
our business to go into the big business
and they figured they could use cameras
and use as art. And I guess they had an
agenda as well, but the vast majority is
what we're talking about, which is just
people that are lost and have a hole in
their hearts looking to fill it somehow.
Um and this provided both the adoration
and the acclamation that that they
desired and the monetary means to to,
you know, to consume the the the the
things that would numb that very pain
and shame that they gained or they they
they contracted from that. So, it's just
one of those vicious circles that the
circle things. But I want to be fair, it
there it wasn't that wasn't everybody.
Yeah, I I want to I want to kind of
circle back around to that because um
you and I had talked a little bit about
you your experience and and actually
your interactions with Ron off set. Um
you know, in fact, your kids even had a
name for him uh and had met him at some
point in in time. You want to share a
little bit about that?
Oh, certainly. I I pictures in my in my
in my our photo albums where Ronny's
babysitting the kids, right? So, there's
Ronny, you know, taking kids to a
to a horse one of his girlfriends
raised horses and there's horseback
riding. Ron was a member of our family,
basically. In fact, even until he had
some He's had some hard luck. He had a
heart attack about 5 years ago and then
he had some legal run-ins
recently. But before that, even after I
got out of the business, Ron was one of
the people that trans that sort of I
kept in touch with through friends and
stuff. Um but yeah, he
it was it was bordering on normalcy, you
know, but even at the time, you I
I use it as a prop, you know, like look
what my life looks like. They're looking
back in the you know,
I mean, you think about you think about
raising children in the fear of the
Lord. You know, that's you know, putting
them into the care I want I want you to
share a little bit about where Ron is
right now
and where he has been. You you had
mentioned at the very beginning of the
show that he has a atheistic and God
point of view like seminar that he
actually travels around with. Tell us a
little bit about that. Sure. So, what I
was telling you before about Ron is that
Ron never gave up his belief in God. And
we had talked we had texted back and
forth this morning Scotty and I about,
you know, how that could be. But when
Ron had a heart attack about four four
or five years ago, I could be wrong, but
is is several years ago he had a heart
attack. Almost died. He was at
Cedars-Sinai.
And as he after he recovered, he began
to go on talk shows and because he was a
celebrity and he would talk and he would
and he would he would find people that
would have an atheistic point of view.
And then he would he would duel them. He
would debate them. And he his of course
was the side that God does exist. And
Ron would use, you know, facts and his
testimony etc. to to do that. Um part of
that I think is is is
and and I I don't want to speak for Ron,
but
but if he sees this he can call me.
Um is I think there is all of us have
adjusted and this is not just in the
business of Ron. All of us have things
in our lives that we justify their
existence. Um and so we can continue to
do that, the sin in our lives. And I
think part of Ron's calculus in this
particular time was, well, maybe God has
me in a place like this so I can use my
influence. And so I can continue to to
to to to move in this world and continue
to be who I am. Um and I just thought
this morning Scotty as you texted back
and forth that that's a good word for
all of us. All of us have something in
our lives that perhaps are
the cherished sin and we one of the
cherished justification is, you know,
what? If I wasn't doing this, I wouldn't
have access to a ministry of people that
would hear this, right? Where um
you know, being clean and living a
God-fearing life is the only testimony
that that is not only required that is
valid, you know. So, right now Ron
unfortunately was um um some people over
the years had uh
recently the political climate has been
selective about the you know, the Me Too
movement. And uh Ron fell afoul of that.
Um and he's in jail right now on charges
um that he coerced uh folks into doing
things. To be honest with you, that's
not the Ron that I knew. I wasn't there
so I can't speak to that. Um
uh one thing I'll tell you about Ron and
it's something that brings up some other
good points is that uh in terms of being
everywhere, when I would go hang out
with Ron in the '80s and he knew, you
know, Axl Rose, we we met Bret Michaels
of Poison. I mean, all those folks knew
him. All those folks grew up with him,
right? You could not go on the street. I
was thinking when I first got into the
business I didn't know who Ron was. And
so I wasn't affected by his fame, but I
would go to the Roxy or the Rainbow or
or just walk anywhere with Ron. School
teachers, police officers in uniform,
18-year-olds, you name it, everyone knew
who he was. An entire generation grew up
knowing this gentleman and it it it all
it never ceased to amaze me. I'd go out
and say, "Wow, Ron." Cuz I thought there
was just a small faction of people that
were just, you know, evil, right? Or not
I don't want to say the word evil, but
they were they were enjoying this type
of uh programming. No, it is everywhere,
right? And so um I remember seeing a
video with Ron um he had another
Christian friend of his that he would go
around and do some of these seminars
with. And um it was really interesting
because Ron had talked about in the
latter part of his his life and they
were sitting down and doing an interview
with him and he was talking about God
and and and the guilt that he felt. And
you know, like, you know, if I died
today, you know, would I be in heaven?
And I think it's really interesting. You
bring up a really good point of if you
go back and look at all these major
people in the Bible, I mean, there are
some terrible things that have been
done. Terrible. I mean, look at Paul. I
mean, he was he was out executing
Christians. And when that guy gets to
heaven, man, you can imagine what a
surprise or yeah, shock that's going to
be. Steve. Yeah. And and you know, this
this I think really brings up a good
good point. I don't believe that there
is anybody too far gone that God cannot
get a hold of their heart. It doesn't
matter what you've done, where you've
gone, what kind of dark rabbit hole you
climbed into that God cannot speak to
your heart. And and you know, maybe
maybe Ron doesn't have it all figured
out right now and he's he's feeling the
consequences of his actions that he has
lived in his life. And and and God's not
going to totally shield you from those
consequences, but he's he's he's feeling
the Holy Spirit's prick in his heart.
And I think that that that is something
that anyone of our viewers can can gain
a blessing from. No matter if you've
gotten involved in the watching the
pornography, you know, we get we get
testimonies from people all the time.
You guys, you know, hear about everybody
that that when we bring up this topic
and they're like, "Oh, please. I I I'm
so addicted to this and please do
something on this topic, right?" I think
here is a prime example of saying, "You
know, what? God can take anybody,
transform them, flip them around. It
doesn't give you license to stay in that
sin or to remain in that sin, but that
God can actually win your heart at any
level." So, you kind of like stole my
whole point there.
And I I'll tell you I I and I wanted a
place to share this this is like a great
place to park this. It's not lost on me
and you and I discussed this I think
earlier this morning that, you know, the
title for
what I did was called director. I was a
producer as well, you know, director.
And now I have a new title. I'm the
director of the Can You Hear Me Now
Ministries. And I love the fact that in
my previous directing stint,
um I was filling the hole that we all
have all these the talent has in their
hearts with fool's gold, with what Satan
has out there, with the with with the
apple, right? With adoration and
acclamation and and and monetary means.
Um that of course is is is futile and is
useless and it's and it and it and it
and it and it it's it actually kills
you. Besides being of no substance. And
then now God has transformed me so I can
sort of be like sort of the the um
the alpha of this in terms of the
example of going from what I was in the
depths. Not only was I participating, I
was creating a world in which it was
possible. I was empowering all this
these people in this pain and this
misery and this guilt. And now God has
brought me out of the mire across and
it's taken years to to move across. And
now I'm director of a ministry that
actually provides this same hole with
the only thing that fits that hole,
right? Which is the which is Jesus
Christ. So, before you before before you
touch on what you're doing now, I kind
of want to toss it up to you because
that's really beautiful. I want you to
to to talk about that. Um
before you mentioned how there's like a
chain
um of of of things that need to happen
before a girl So, a girl may start off,
okay, just take off your shirt here, but
then she reaches to the point where
she's fully naked on screen. And um I
wonder if that is the process of numbing
someone or a process of preparation to
get to that point. And when we see what
happens to us, um not just with the
numbness, not the people in the
industry, but those viewing it, how Chad
was showing statistics that it actually
the brain matter, the gray matter,
sorry, in your brain actually shrinks as
you're continuously watching this
content. But just as you go down that
chain of of degradation and and pain and
and ruining your life, there's that
hopeful but that you can turn around and
head in the direction of restoration.
So, I'd like you to touch on that. What
was your journey of restoration? What
are you doing now that is such in
contrast to what you were doing before?
Great question. Um this this process has
been a long one. So, the events we're
talking about were happening in the late
'80s. I didn't give my heart to Jesus
Christ until 2003. My backstory is that
my father was a an evangelist and
missionary in the Seventh-day Adventist
church. So, I grew up um in the in the
late '60s, early '70s in in what I call
checklist Christianity. And so I I I
rejected that as a as a youngster. I
realized right away I knew there was a
God. I knew that there was a
accountability for my actions. But I
thought about it's either hell now and
heaven later or heaven now and hell
later. And I'm living now and so and I
so I just didn't want to be disingenuous
like some of my brethren and so I took
off as hard and as fast as I could.
Like I said earlier, that the porn
experience wasn't um
it wasn't singular. I remember going my
first time in a nightclub, hearing the
music there and feeling very surreal. It
took a while for and I love what Keith
and you said about the the this process.
There is a process. So, my my
downgrading from being sensitive to
spiritual matters to where I could move
in these circles with with no
um static took time. As it went down, I
went to a nightclub the first time and
it was weird. The first time I I cheated
on my wife, that was weird. All all
these things, you know, they're in my
heart and it so it took a while to go
down. Uh and so when I came out of the
porn business, I didn't do it for
spiritual purposes. Although I looking
back I realized that God was was leading
me and God was uh resensitizing my
heart. Uh I did it for, you know,
maturity reasons in terms of myself, you
know, looking at my family and looking
at where I wanted to go.
Um and so but God had other issues he
was dealing with in in the '90s I and
2003 I was broken for another reason. Uh
I was my
my background is is to be nefarious, is
to be
uh is to be dishonest, is to be, you
know, less than transparent and and and
make money and do things that way. And
so God had led me down a path where that
my world just collapsed in 2003 or 2000
2 and 2001. And I remember being um I
was living in Burbank at the time. Um
and I remember that there was a church
in Glendale I'd seen all the time, the
big church on the hill. And uh I had
done drugs night before. I probably
still had some of my system. I
put my uh big trench coat on, my Ray
my Ray-Bans on. And that morning I had
went to church and I sat in the very
back of the balcony. And I liked that
church cuz it was an intimate there was
not a lot of people going to ask me
stuff. They go away in the back there.
And as God would have it, um
a Hispanic woman was up there speaking
on grace. Uh Elizabeth Talbot, it turned
out to be. She was the associate pastor
there at the time. She's on on stage and
she talked about grace and I'm 39 years
old, raising that business and for the
first time in my life I'm being
confronted
by the love of God who loves me right
where I was.
And I just started to cry and bubbles
came out of my nose. Thank God for the
Ray-Bans with my Ray-Bans and and I gave
my life to God right there. And then
then the then the rest has been sort of
a progression as I move forward, you
know, up and down jagged steps. Um and
to your specific question which changed
now is that that I'm 59 years old now
and I realized I gave my youth to
the pursuits of the enemy.
And I feel like I need to make sure that
the time that I have now is well
leveraged to make sure that every
minute, every hour I can do the Lord's
work because there are so many souls
like this that are lost in pornography
or drug use or or and right now a new
and now we have new flavors. We have
political activism. We have so many
different things and the devil doesn't
care what it is as long as you're not
looking at Jesus. Just don't look at
Jesus. You can work on a good cause. I'm
good with that. But just don't look at
Jesus.
And so
so that's so that's sort of my point now
is to sort of drill through and and
spend as much time as I can as many
years as God has blessed me with going
forward
to spend the same amount of energy and
passion on winning souls for Christ.
Amen. And beautiful. And I just want to
put a little plug in there for the Can
You Hear Me Now
because I have been able to by God's
grace is attend this conference many
times actually and it's a it's a group
in in Los Angeles that really reaches
out to
this sort of people at the end of their
rope. There is a lot of people that that
that are coming to this conference and
and and hearing some amazing messages
and transforming their lives. There's
baptisms that happened there and so I
always look forward to actually going to
this conference and and visiting with
you guys and I'll tell you what it it it
is amazing to hear your story. Now when
I met you John, I knew barely a little
bit. I'd heard a little bit of this but
I didn't know at what extent you had
gotten involved in this and it just
never never never fails to shock me that
you know what God is such a gentleman.
He's so patient and he's so patient with
us no matter how far we walk away. We've
slapped him, spit in his face, ruined
his children, done anything like this
and you know what he takes us back with
these loving arms and then just just
says you know what? I'm going to put you
in a position where you can now turn
around and win souls for me. You you you
were directing a soul losing soul
destroying business. Now you are
directing a soul winning industry and
and I just think man what greater
testimony does it get like that? You
know what I mean?
Praise God.
You know Scotty and my
my my I have a new marriage and my my
daughter you met her Ariana and Aiden.
She's she's 17 now. Aiden's 11 and when
she had her quinceanera my wife's from
Mexico so when she had her quinceanera a
couple years ago
there was this thing in the family where
don't Google Dad. You can't Google Dad
until you're 15, right? And so at 15 so
that was sort of a joke but then at 15
it became like what are you going to do?
You know, are you going to Google Dad
type of thing, right? And so I will tell
you this and so sometimes my wife my
wife
spans my my reclamation so she remembers
me as as a heathen, as a pagan, as a as
a God as a John worshipping, you know,
young man or a younger man. And so
sometimes the kids will be like Dad the
spiritual one. Dad's so and godly and my
wife will roll her eyes, look at her and
go do you know who you're talking about?
And I say this only to say this. I
believe that to my kids, you know, we we
teach them as much as we can and we have
worship and they go to church etc. But I
think the biggest impact on their life
is their understanding of their dad's
reclamation. They understand the any any
authenticity they see their dad's
journey, they just suppose that against
where he's been and they see the power
of God to move a life from there to
there. They didn't witness those things
but they hear enough about them to
realize that it's real and it's powerful
and I I love that that piece of it and I
hope any of your viewers who are hearing
this
and it's not by John's grace, it's by
God's grace that this all happens, you
know,
and that is real and that's and it works
in my family in my very blood children
as they grow up. So I have a I have a a
question.
Have you been able to be instrumental
in
bringing other people to Christ from
your past experiences?
I have not.
I I just like I said there was a um
a
period of time between my exit in the
business and now so my
intercourse with those people or was
very limited
but the ones that I have like I I I had
I had a production assistant that was um
it was basically John's right hand man.
I mean I remember I don't want to tell
you stories but whatever I asked for he
would do. He's a great gentleman from
New York. So him and I still talk, we
pray together and his daughter got
married, he asked me to come say a few
words
and then Tony Montana, he knows where I
am and we've prayed together and and and
I ministered to his wife when he when he
goes he's had losses and I've gone down
there and and and read scripture for him
as well. So the ones that I have in my
life keep I do but I don't have a
ministry to that for probably a couple
reasons as I think about it. One, I
don't have the access to that. Number
two, you got to remember this was not a
passion of mine. I I did this because
you know, my life sort of led me in that
direction
and so
I don't I don't feel connection in some
ways and so to go back there after this
time
wasn't something that was was high on
the list of things that was natural for
me to do. But the ones that are in my
lives absolutely and to them they can't
believe it either. I mean they I mean
they you can imagine what they've seen.
What art I've been to that, right?
Forget my kids. I mean these people saw
me in those spots and then they see me
preach um like these two have and
they're like dude dude.
I have another question. I think
and you may or may not know.
Is there any resources besides Can You
Hear Me Now
that you know of or that you would
recommend to people who are either
struggling with pornography, they're in
the industry, they they're at the end of
their rope, they want to get out, you
know, anything like that that you have
come across or know about and you say
yeah, this is a great resource to help
educate you and and deliver you from
that experience?
Forgive me Keith and panel. I knew this
was going to come up and I was starting
to there was none on my fingertips but I
started doing a little bit of research
to pull them together and I had not
completed by the time we were
taping this so I could send it to you
later on if you had folks that wanted to
to chime in. There was two or three
different organizations.
Fight the Fight the New Drug Yeah,
that's one that I Yeah, that's one that
I think is you know, I when we started
doing research and I signed up for that
as well and they they do email quite a
bit. They they keep a connection and I
know
you know, part of one of the things that
gets people out of this vicious cycle of
pornography is really accountability.
You know, as I kind of sit and listen to
this, you know, amazing testimony of
grace how God has had grace on your
life.
You know, I think of biblical stories of
other people that that Jesus personally
had grace on. One of them was Mary
Magdalene and in fact you know, when
Jesus
it says in Luke I think do you remember
what verse that was that we were talking
about earlier? Luke
Luke 8. Luke 8:22 I think. Let me see
here. Um
when it talks about you know, seven
demons. 8:2?
Yeah, 8:2. Um 8 Luke 8:2 says
In fact did you pull it up? Yeah, it
says
and read it. And certain women who had
been healed of evil spirits and
infirmities, Mary called Magdalene out
of whom had come seven demons. You know,
this is the one you know, in Matthew or
Mark 16:9 it says basically the same
thing but you know, I was making note
that she appeared first, you know, she
was the first one to come to the tomb
when Jesus rose from the grave. And I
think you know, what's kind of
interesting as we started discussing
this is it's like you know, to mention
that that seven spirits came out of her
and it doesn't quite give that detail of
was it all at once? Was it in a row? But
I imagine that you know, maybe this
wasn't something that that even Mary
Magdalene was able to get over
immediately. Jesus had to keep coming
back and showing her that same amount of
grace and I think kind of part of the
the problem of getting caught in this
vicious cycle of pornography is the
shame of like ah how did I get here
again and again and again and it's like
you know, you go for a while and then
it's like I'm here again and what am I
doing? And and my my my answer to that
would be like go to the Bible. Look at
the examples of how God has graciously
time and time again given people hey,
I'm here for you. I love you and I want
to help you through this experience. And
so um there's a lot of resources I know
we we started mentioning that because of
Fight the New Drug you know, to kind of
stay up and sharpen that tool because
you know, the devil may leave you alone
for a little while. Oh yeah, you got
this. You feeling pretty good? Watch
this.
You know, and then he comes right back
in to the floodgates and something that
is so intimately tied into the core of
who we are as humans, our sexuality.
That's not something to just trifle with
and you know, you have to be able to
take the proper steps to get out of
that. So
you know, we'll definitely post in the
description below. There's there's
enough resources. We'll put some links
in those descriptions below but but
certainly if anybody is is struggling
with this, feel free to reach out to us.
You know, if you have other questions
for John, we'll put his contact details.
If you want him to come and talk at your
church, we'll put his details in the the
the description below and and
definitely Uh, check out Can You Hear me
now? I think it's can you hear me
now.org, right?
Yes, can you hear me now.org, yes. And
and it's really an evangelism school.
So, you know, there's a number of these
evangelism schools that you guys um can
look into and it really gives you the
tools of of how to digest the Bible, how
to get to the to the bottom of what you
believe, how how to really start to
learn to have a relationship with Jesus.
These are all things that you'll learn
from can you hear me now. So, a
relationship with Jesus is so important.
But
Yeah.
how important do you think
relationships are?
Um like between humans? Cuz you were
saying that you would look at your
daughter and as you saw her grow, it
made you change your view of these girls
that you were filming. So, someone who
has an addiction to pornography or maybe
who is in this world
um how important do you think their own
personal relationships are? Do you think
that they should go
work in um
you know, day camps or something like
that? Surround themselves with with
things that can kind of like I don't
know, humanize them a little bit more.
It's kind of break them out of this uh
tunnel that they're in.
Candy, just to break character for a
second, I just love watching you over
the years. I this is exactly your kind
of a question in terms of taking and
putting a new prism on it. I love that.
So, thank you for for doing that. I
think that's an amazing idea cuz you're
you're exactly right.
We have a relationship with our with our
father that's broken. That's that's
that's that's altered, right? And so,
many times God uses relationships in our
lives to mirror him that to to to
restore that, right? And so, the more
more relationships you have and
sometimes it's just one. Some of the
people that we're talking to or
listening to this just have one
relationship with one person that that
can that can save them that they're that
the mirror that they look at when they
see them gives them enough to give them
hope, right? And give them
a way to move forward. And so, the more
of those that you establish absolutely.
I think that'd be a great idea. I was
fortunate uh probably you know,
providential that I had a child growing
up. And a father's love for his child,
God leveraged that to to overlay what I
was going through to to make sure that
he broke his son, you know, away from
that. Uh I also want to hearken back to
what Scotty said. This is so important.
It's like I I'm I'm um
a reformed cigarette smoker. And so, I
know what it's like to quit over and
over again and the shame and the guilt
and you start to think that it's not it
can never happen. And you know,
those of us who have been in in in the
in that side of the business or even
those who just watch pornography know
that there's a point where it seems
glorious and there's a point where it's
shame and guilt and they're not that far
apart. And so, every time you go there,
it it just you feel it feels like
failure, right? It feels like I can
never do this. And if you do it 10
times, you feel that low. Imagine doing
it 100 times. I know the folks I'm
talking to right now, they know this cuz
I went through this over and over. And
it can be interminable, it seems
sometimes. But I love what Scotty said
that God is always grace
full of grace for everybody no matter if
it's 10 or 100 or 1,000 or whatever it
is. And the way I reference that in my
mind is I say to myself, we live in
time. And we decide that God sees me now
and I'm clean, I'm pure and I'm not ever
going to do that again.
And then the then tomorrow when we do
that, we think, "Oh my gosh, now God is
upset with me. God was happy with me
yesterday cuz I was clean and and
committed good. And tomorrow when I fail
again for the thousandth time, now he's
unhappy." And to remind ourselves that
God lives outside of time. When you
thought God was happy with you, he
already knew tomorrow was going to
happen and he was still happy with you.
He still loved you. He still had grace
for you.
So so, it it helped it helps me to
remember that as I struggle with things
I struggle with. That as high as I feel
today because I feel like I've given it
up and as low as I feel tomorrow, that
the same God shines his love on me in
both ways. And I need to I need to get
the feeling from the former day and
shine on the sun the on the on the
latter day to give me strength to move
forward. So.
I just want to piggyback on that
thought, Scotty. I thought that was I'll
bring that back around um to what the
Bible says. In 2 Corinthians 5:17, it
says, "Therefore, if anyone is in
Christ,
he is a new creation.
Old things have passed away. Behold, all
things have become new." New creation is
a clean slate, right? It means what was
before is no more.
And so, you have no matter if it's
pornography or alcohol or other drugs or
any other addiction, whatever it is that
you're struggling with, God says, "I
will wipe that away. I will wipe the
slate clean. You will start over. You
will be new
in me."
And also, there is a great verse in Jude
1:24 that says, "To him who is able to
keep you from stumbling and to present
you before his glorious presence without
fault and and listen to this. This fits
in greatly with what you just said, with
great joy." Mhm. Yeah. Like even even
even, you know, he wants to present you
and say, "I'm proud of this person right
here." You know, sometimes we do have
that distorted view that God is angry
with us or if we just don't do the right
things, he's going to be mad at us. But
here, this is a picture of God saying,
"Listen, I'm able to keep you from
falling and I'll I'll present you with
with with exceeding joy." You I I like
these. They're kind of long, but I like
these restoration videos where they
take, you know, a piece of hardware
equipment and it's like rusted and
crusty and just like how could that ever
work or be used again? A guy takes it
apart,
polishes everything, you know, replaces
it, straightens it, you know,
you know, brings it back around from
being twisted, whatever he's got to do.
And by the time you get to the end of
the video,
it's completely new again. And that's
what heaven is going to be like. It's
going to be
full of God's restoration projects. And
I I imagine that's what is bringing God
so much joy. It's like, "Look, you know,
not only did I make them from the
beginning, but I I remade them and look
what they look what they've become now,
you know?" And keep this in mind, too.
Yeah, that is that is beautiful.
Keep this in mind, too. When when it was
asked, you know, Jesus was trying to
illustrate a point and he was saying,
"Who who is going to be happier? The
person that, you know, is forgiven Yeah.
or the person that's forgiven a lot?"
So, if you've climbed into the deeper,
darkest rabbit hole and God has snatched
you out of that, right? I mean, there's
there should not be shame, but
excitement and joy that God can bring
you out of that depth. I think that was
in the context of um Mary, wasn't it?
Yeah. Yeah, Simon and Mary, yeah.
And also
Yeah, and and also uh what you were
saying they
we had those holes, right? Uh and when
we come to Christ,
he is the one that who's going to supply
with all our needs. Mhm. And I say joy,
love, and sometimes we like a how we can
compare, you know, the love of God, the
love of, you know, pornography, all
those sexual stuff. But let me tell you,
when Christ is in our hearts, I mean,
seriously, I mean, it's like
like right now, I mean, the joy that you
have right now is just to share the
gospel, you know? Mhm. I mean, it's like
I cannot wait to make another video,
right?
Yeah. I cannot wait just to edit
something or like put this thing there
or like have a Bible study with
somebody. As it now now is that joy
replace
the, you know, all that all the videos.
The other joy is only temporary. Yeah.
That's that's one of the big
differences. Yeah. Well, anybody else
got any other final questions here for
John?
I have some facts. I don't know if I
should share.
share. Uh when I went to uh for a family
vacation, we went to uh Tahoe uh Lake
Tahoe. Mhm. And we stop at uh a small
town. My first time going to Reno,
California. No, Reno, Nevada. Mhm.
And I mean, I knew it, you know, it's
casinos and stuff like that, right? So,
we just, you know, for a couple days and
then we just drove to Lake Tahoe.
And you know, we were driving around
and the city, I mean, I mean, homeless
and a lot of homeless there woman. Oh,
interesting.
And they look Tore up.
very bad. I mean, seriously, very bad.
And we I mean, I I didn't know like why
is, you know,
and somebody told, you know, I asked. I
was like, "Why is a lot of women's
here?"
They got into
pornography and and
you know,
sex life. I mean, how do you can call it
like
there's not a retirement plan package
attached to this industry. No 401k. No
401k. So, what what you were saying
like, you know, after a while, I mean,
you get to age 30 or I don't know how
many times or something like that. It's
like
No, after a year. After a year. Oh,
yeah. They're
mainly kicked into the gutter when
you're like done, used up, see you, we
don't want you anymore. Are they sexy
for like the rest of your life? That one
They pay the price for their entire life
for a year of bad choices. That's You
can see those those ladies, you know, in
the streets and all that stuff. I mean,
it's like
really bad. I mean, so
you know what's sad to me, we didn't we
didn't quite um tackle this when you
guys were talking about the details of
of, you know, the payment and that's why
people kind of get involved in it is the
money and everything, right? But you
know, the devil has put a price tag on
every one of our heads, right? He's put
a price tag that's like, "You are only
worth this much." And it's such a such
an opposite view of what Jesus has done
because he's saying, "No, no, no, there
is no price on your head. It is
infinitely valuable to me. I would
rather cease to exist so that you have
an opportunity to exist." That's that's
the price that Jesus has placed upon us.
And the devil has just manipulated these
people to think that their value comes
with a certain number. And anytime I
hear a celebrity say, "Oh, yeah, this
celebrity makes $20 million." It's like,
"Yeah, but that's still a price tag."
You know what I mean? Whereas, I don't
have a price tag. It's infinitely
valuable in God's eyes. Yeah. And
Scotty, you can you can extrapolate that
and even apply it to just the world in
general, you know, cuz we talk about
eight-month, 12-month shelf life of
somebody using. And what's what's the
transaction? I'm using my beauty what
God has given me, right? To be able to
get whatever I'm looking to get. Well,
that's that's transactional, but all of
us in some way, shape, or form use that
through our lives. And you see that in
terms of men and women as they grow
older, and all of a sudden their value
fades, right? Because they're using the
exact same currency. They use it
differently, and it's not quite as
transactional, but everyone knows how
that works, you know, in terms of, you
know, the the woman at 20 and 30 gets
what she wants typically. When she gets
a little bit older, all of a sudden it
changes. I went through that as I got
older. I started seeing my dry cleaner
not pay attention to me. I'm like,
"Whoa, what's happening?" Right? We all
go through that, right? Because we put
value in that. So, it's not just a
lesson for those that are involved in
the business. It's a lesson for all of
us. I love what you said, that we have
we have the crowning glory of God's
creation. That's who I am. That's who
you are, regardless of what how tall you
are, how old you are, what you look
like. And and anytime we deviate from
that our value being derived from our
relationship with him, from being God's
creation, we will be in trouble.
Yeah. So. I don't know if we have time
for this, but
you said you saw a bunch of women on the
streets, but it's not only women that
are involved in the porn industry. Can
you speak to
what's happening to the guys?
Um I I honestly feel almost
well, as bad for the guys themselves,
cuz they I don't think many of the guys
felt like they were just because of we
have a very misogynist type of society,
and they felt like I don't think they
felt
the shame and the guilt in the same way.
But, this stuff is spiritual. This stuff
is emotional. This stuff corrodes you
from the inside. And none of them that I
knew, except for my friend Tony, you
know, made it out of that. They all
you know, and they and they were much
heavier drug users than the girls.
Um
a testimony from one of the guys on the
Fight the New Drug. He was kind of a
larger gentleman,
and he was you know, he his claim to
fame was he was one of the highest paid
male actors, and you know, he would
spout off all the stats and everything.
And he said he so disliked himself, he
hated himself. He would fantasize about,
you know, committing suicide, and he
would just do drugs to just try to numb
it as best as he could. And he just got
the drug. He was literally doing the
porn so that he could just take the
money from the porn set, literally
walking over, handing it to his drug
dealer, and and it was just this vicious
cycle.
So,
They're waiting outside. We we go on set
if we traveled, it wasn't the the case.
Or they bring they they If someone's if
if talent said to me, "John, can you
hire this lighting guy?" That was code
for, you know, he's my guy. But, if we
shot locally, oh, they were waiting.
They were texting them, you know, or
calling them saying, "I'm getting off
set at 8:00." Um yeah, that's exactly
that is a very common what you just
said. Take John's money, and just give
it right to somebody else. It just
speaks to the nature of what a predator
Satan is. You know, and the Bible says
that. It says that he's like this
roaring like and roaring lion seeking
whom he can devour, you know? And here
they are, it's like, yeah, you know, you
you you go into this with the idea of uh
I'll have money, therefore I'll be
happy. And then you realize you're not
happy, and then you're using your money
to try to buy your happiness. And the
next thing you know, you have neither.
First hit's always free, right? And then
it's just,
you know, pain from there on out.
Wow, John, thank you so much. Any final
questions? Thank you so much for coming
on and sharing with us.
Um you know, I just absolutely think
that we can't talk enough about this
subject, especially whenever I talk to
young people and I hear what a struggle
that they're experiencing. The world
it's not just only guys anymore, it's
girls are having the same amount of
struggling as this. Um we've had a
number of people on our show that that
would talk about those experiences. I
shared with my team an experience this
last week that is just like, it's
mind-blowing when I hear these things,
and I and I go, "They're so evil, John.
We can't even speak of them out of our
mouths." But, then I think about the the
time that Paul would say the same sort
of thing. He's like, you know, I can't
even talk about the evils that are
happening within this church. This is
nothing new. There's nothing new under
the sun. It it it has gotten evil to the
point where God wanted to wipe out
humanity and start over. And so, you
know, we're back at that same place, and
I believe that our only safety is to get
on the ark, the ark of Christ, and and
and he is our safety and surety. He
always provides a way of escape. That's
right.
Thank you so much for sharing, and we'll
put his contact details in the
description below, but we hope you guys
were blessed. Please like, subscribe,
share this video. There's a lot of
people that need to to have some light
shown on this particular topic, and we
just thank you guys so much for all the
love and support you've given to our
ministry over the years, and we hope
that you enjoyed today's talk, and we'll
see you next Friday.